what's going on guys national master
james kante the third here with
chess.com and today we have the top
five swindles swindles guys i'm sure
you've been there before maybe you've
swindled a game of two or two
in your life but this is the top five
swindles from some of the best
in the speed chess championships in this
first game we have alexander grishik vs
magnus carlsen this was back in 2017
yes 2017 guys so let's see what happens
white actually just played queen e3 so
alexander grisham just played queen e3
in this weird position guys a lot going
on back rank is covered by black
maybe even the light squares could be a
problem for white here but also there's
like
checks and like maybe even some type of
mates like some type of
you know 97s and queen g5s and mates
there's
there's stuff going on this is a
powerful position here
after queen e3 this is what magnus does
magnus just
plays queen d7 what queen d7
it's a very rare blunder at this level
guys but it's a blunder
queen d7 what happens after queen d7
what would you play here fight to move
guys queen d7 is a blunder
here it is knight f6 very simple thanks
for the queen
i'm sure alexander grishik was like what
am i
am i being tricked i mean what is this
knight f6 and here it is the queen falls
guys
the queen falls and then he follows up
this is not even the swindle part
it looks like black's just lost right
maybe some counter play especially with
some checks and like
things can happen the rook's on the back
rank so it is pretty scary still
here we go he says f4 so i'm just going
to move my king to f2
actually after this but here is the
swindling part guys
now the best move actually let's go back
here queen to d3 is actually the best
move is what they call
eyeballing shout out to yasser shiron is
what he would say here queen to d3
eyeballing
the d7 and the g6 square as well this is
a nasty move here and then
after we have a bishop c6 bishop d5
capture capture
and then um white's really playing for
two results here so
uh either winning or drawing now going
back here he actually played f4 in this
position after bishop takes
grisham chose f4 leading us into rookie
eight now there's
all kind of damage that's about to
happen to white's position here so after
rook two eight he's in a lot of trouble
here actually
so he just gives it back he just says
all right cool you know what
hey i'll give you your queen back let's
see what we can do here but
look at this position now guys what a
swindle i lost my queen i got it back
now can i win this game well let's see
rook b4 king g7 king f2 a5 we're just
going to push to pass pawn rook b8 and
bishop c6
a lot of moves here so we're going to
fast forward some rook b6
uh we're k3 here bishop d1 we're going
to fast forward some moves here guys
pawn takes and rook g1 we're just we're
just maneuvering that's
that's kind of what they're doing
maneuvering trying to pro make some
weaknesses here
i also put some threats on the board
here as much as we can so king d4
steps off of it you take mine i take
yours bishop b7 you take mine i take
yours
and now guys whoa what happened here i'm
up two pawns in an end game
what i was down a queen though or down
the exchange for the queen
now i'm actually in the position to win
this game says magnus
now after rook here we're gonna sack our
rook on this all day and every day in
any way
so let's see what happens we push some
pawns here pawns get pushed
king walks up a little bit we capture i
queen view queen but with check
now he moves out of the way and then the
rest honestly is technique from here
these are hard end games but especially
with this past pawn here
black has a huge chance of winning this
game so after a few checks or a lot of
checks actually
a lot of checking being done king moves
around does what he has to do
then we go back to the back rank and go
here and then
he resigns that was it he resigned like
right here he just resigned right here
because there's no way to stop queen g6
jack
also queen e7 check if you check me
anywhere i'm gonna go queen e7 and this
is queening
easily i mean this is elementary uh in
game from here guys what a swindle
actually looking back at that guys
looking back at that right here
just going back to it we lost our queen
this is why you don't give up
we lost our queen magnus says yeah i
lost it did he resign no he kept playing
he kept playing on f4 rookie eight wow i
get my queen back because there's mating
threats
and all kind of nasty things happening
after check here i mean even if you move
your queen like queen c5 to stop the
check
that's checkmate or almost it actually
had to block with the queen on f2 but
then bishop c6 oh my goodness let's just
oh my goodness that's just too many
things going on here so he just he just
said forget it let's just take it
and then we go into a winning end game
what a swindle guys this will swindle
number one now let's move on to swindle
number two
and here we are with swindle number two
this is york meyer with the white pieces
versus sergey
karyakin with the black pieces in 2017.
so let's see what happened here guys in
this position actually queen f7 was the
last
move played by sergey now sergey is
under some pressure here guys this looks
kind of weird looking
this pawn's hanging we got a pass pawn
here i mean there's a lot going on even
the bishop is aiming on this side of the
board but we do have some compensation
with the pass pawn in the center but not
realistically because it can always be
stopped here so it's kind of just like
dynamic to say the least here now here's
what happens immediately
york meyer just plays rook takes b6 and
we're like hey we're just going to take
the pawn
pretty simple here there should be
nothing but there actually
is something here black to move guys
what do you actually do here in this
position
here we go sergey actually just played
rook to d1 check rook d1 check if you
take my rook i'm going to take your
queen
so this is automatic king f2 is forced
and then knight to d3
wow now we're in a driver's seat now
we're picking up some material after you
just snapped this pawn here
thinking you were winning well think
again king to g3 knight takes c1
queen to c6 just stepping out of the way
actually also hitting his rook
as well so we move our rook to f8 just
bring everything to this side of the
board
where your king is now after bishop
takes c1 queen takes f5
a5 and then e4 and now this is very
scary i mean there's a check here
pawn takes is coming queen g6 check
looks and it looks pretty nice too
you have a lot of moves here and you're
also threatening to take this just in
case
a6 was played and then e takes f3 and
circuit karaoke
actually won this game right here
right here he won the game york meyer
just resigned and
honestly it is uh it's just over here
but there's a lot of things that you can
do from this position
queen g6 is especially after queen takes
f3 and if pawn takes we may even have
rook g1 check in some cases
maybe queen g6 first and then queen to g
oh my goodness it's just
there's so much going on guys there's so
much going on but the swindle happened
back here after queen f7 queen c4 queen
f7
we had the block and white's giving some
pressure to black here i mean if you
look at this position
even now if queen f7 wasn't to move
where you kind of need
need that to happen but it's not the
easiest position to play here as black
yeah you are hitting this pawn but this
is hanging this is hanging the rooks are
coordinated
nicely the bishop's looking good the
rook's kind of misplaced to be honest it
looks kind of weird here on the d5
square
so queen f7 we defend it and then man
there's our chance we take it
every time we see our chance rook d1
king f2 93 and the rest
is history nice swindle here by
sergey karyakin to go on and win this
game and now
we're gonna move on to swindle number
three now with swindle number three this
one is so awesome guys this is actually
one that you may even see in your own
games and a concept
that you should definitely remember this
game is actually anishkiri
versus wesley so with the black pieces
back in 2017
let's actually see what's going on here
black is about to queen wesley so
is trying to clean one of these pawns as
quickly as possible especially this
one's going to queen because this one
can't yet because of this
and you can't actually push this pawn
because the the this is this is here
it just doesn't seem right here you also
have like maybe checks and takes and
you're able to hold as black here while
you're also able to try to queen this
pawn at the same time
but here's what anish giri did anish
geary looked around the board
and understood all of his resources and
he plays rook to g3
now the game should be drawn but
he actually sets a very clever trap here
what do you think he's doing
well wesley so says b3 i don't know what
you're doing i have
i don't understand i don't understand
and after b3 guys
what do you actually do now here's what
is what was supposed to happen is
actually bishop to b5
and after rook takes the bishop to c4
because this pawn is not really
promoting
and the king has to step off we can also
step up and we have a pawn of our own
so there's too many things this should
be drawn but actually
that was not to move wesley so actually
chose b3 trying to queen in this
position
what do you do now anish geary what do
you do now
like to move here it is guys here it is
swindu
f7 f7 i don't care what you do
you're gonna lose this game now there is
checkmate on the back ring
and if we try check well we take it and
then we come and grab this pawn with our
king and this one with our rook
and then it's king rick versus king very
simple easy win there guys what a
swindle
i mean it's so like such a deadly move
but so quiet at the same time
rick to g3 nothing so he plays b3 wesley
cells like ah i'm gonna queen
and then f7 and he's like i'm not gonna
queen anything
and the game is over on the spot what a
swindle congratulations to anishgiri for
that one
that was really nice guys now let's move
on to swindle number four
now for swindle number four we have yani
pomniacci versus levon nickleronion in
2017 guys let's check this out this is a
roy lopez morphe defense cozio defense
actually
and here's what happened so lebron
ironian actually
first off his kings in the center so
let's see what happens here this is a
wild game guys and watch the sequence of
moves that's about to happen
knight takes d4 first off of course we
can't take
just because uh you know obvious reasons
our queen is just hanging
so he plays bishop b4 not only hitting
the rook but also defending f3 as well
okay rook moves out of the way and here
we go guys are you ready for this
knight takes d4 i don't even care that
you're taking my queen
i don't care says yan
prominent now the queen sack is unsound
in a way but of course even at the high
level here you have to be extremely
accurate and it is
definitely scary so now let's see what
happens what's his intention did we just
take back on d1
actually no in between moves this is a
knight to c6 beautiful move here
actually hitting the queen and the
knight at the same time your opponent
will be so unexpected
when he sees this on the board now
bishop takes c3 was the wrong move
actually here
wrong move bishop takes c3 uh actually
knight takes c6 was the best way to play
believe it or not
and after bishop takes king f8 rook
takes in queen f6
bishop to d7 rook d8 bishop takes c7
rook takes rook takes and then king ga
now this is the
refutation of it but of course there's
still some complex
to it and some complexity to it but
black is objectively just better um here
but it is
it's gonna be a fight it is gonna be a
fight but this is the way that he should
have proceeded here but actually he took
on c3
and after bishop takes pawn takes so now
we actually have the bishop pair on top
of the queen set
so after knight takes c1 c6 bishop takes
king f8
rook takes and then queen to f6 now
let's see what happens here guys let's
look at the position we got two rooks
actually kind of one because this one's
not doing anything the king is unsafe we
got bishop swiping the board and two
rooks
i mean this is definitely some
compensation here so bishop to d7
threatening the rook after rook d8 ouch
and there we are with the skewer and
that is the problem with the bishop
takes c3 move
because with it without bishop take c3
the skewer wouldn't be allowed
and now we would be able to keep some
material on the board now this is enough
to win here
after bishop takes h8 f6 and then h4
c5 and then rook to d5 guys king to g8
bishop check
and then bishop back to d7 now here
watch this best move here
bishop c6 beautiful move beautiful move
because now i'm going to take
and then check on the back rank if you
of course defend your rook now if he
takes the bishop
which he does then we take and h5
cut the king off make sure he's stuck in
here there's a mate threat on the board
king f7 he comes around the back way
here
check double the rooks because we have
to
queen here to d5 rook d7 game's over
swindle swin duel
swindle guys what a swindle okay man
he was not hey this queen sack is not
supposed to work and he's done it before
too this is not the first time he's ever
done this queen site
not that it's not supposed to work but
it's hard finding the refutation to it
because we're not computers so now after
this bishop takes d1
knight c6 beautiful beautiful and play
here bishop d7
bishop b5 now we take the other rook and
then we need to cut some things off
okay bring the check in bring the bishop
back around
bishop to c6 here and the game is over
very soon yani pamniacci
was a monster for this swindle here and
after rook here the game's over because
we have a check mate here and a
checkmate here
and if you take of course obvious
reasons you just lose it's rook versus
everything else
and bringing the queen to g8 is
checkmate bringing a queen here
it's it just doesn't work everything's
losing so
of course uh yanipaniachi wins in this
position right here guys that was
swindle number four
and now let's move on to the final
swindle of today
and here we go guys the last swindle of
today
here we are guys this is magnus carlson
versus wesley so with the black pieces
back in 2017
let's actually see what happened here
this started as already ended up in some
kind of kings indian attack
and b5 was just played by wesley cell so
magnus says okay we're going to capture
then capture back and then we take on a
a and then take on a8 honestly guys
looks objectively drawn
there is some play there is some play
from both sides here especially a
queen side play here this pawn is very
weak and also white just has kind of
some dynamicism in the center maybe we
can break this down play some c4
and just kind of see what happens here
white's not hoping for a lot here but we
are we still have to play on so after
knight to e3
rook to d8 and then after knight takes
d5 the game is
just drawn after he takes d5 and uh of
course you have to still play on you got
to be accurate you still have to
you know work for this draw but it's not
that easy actually e takes d5
should be the best move but here's what
wesley so chose
to he does rick takes d5 it takes d5
seems like a simple move right
seems like everything's fine or is it
guys or
is it what would you play in this
position if you were magnus here what
would you play with white
here it is guys here it is queen takes
d5
whoa magnus carlsen wins by resignation
although the game should have been drawn
after he takes d5
because now after pawn takes rook check
bishop f8
and bishop to h6 very nice way
to finish off a win here now of course
this is a winning end game and
he did go on to win this game actually
but it was a draw and actually uh
it was a draw and wesley cell just
resigned
queen takes d5 he was like ah oh my
goodness
the game should be a draw you know
actually after uh he takes d5
rookie a bishop f8 bishop h6 and uh he
win
he won this game from the resignation to
be honest but uh queen takes d5 he takes
d5 it's just a draw but
the queen sacrifice was so stunning that
he just resigned before he got here
that's what happened sometimes sometimes
you ever seen that move or you ever
played that move on the board and you've
seen it happen
and they're like oh my goodness i can't
believe i missed that
and it's actually a draw i've been there
many times i'm sure you probably have
before
especially after analyzing your game
perfect example here from two monsters
actually queen takes d5 should be just a
draw
because of course he takes you know rook
check now of course you can
uh there is some some play here you have
some things to do takes takes
and this should be a draw but of course
you know the king is a little bit closer
we could also maybe try to work some
things in but objectively just kind of
drawing three versus three right
three versus three this was the top five
swindles
of the speed chess championship guys i
hope you enjoyed today's video and i'm
national master james canty the third
and i'll see you guys
on the next video